what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich and the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right i am
right here with plenty evil over
marinova popliano
in the house lunch money is not
sponsored by block five that means go
get a blackfy account blockfy.com
pomp you can earn up to 8.6 percent apy
an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto take out a us dollar
alone to get your crypto
collateral you can buy and sell crypto
on their crypto exchange with no
fees or you can sign up for the waitlist
that bitcoin rewards credit card is
coming when the credit card is here
y'all gonna be freaking out so go get on
the wait list now
blockfy.com pomp sorry guys i was rushed
out of the shower
that's why my hair's still wet thanks to
our friends
you see a little tricep action right
there i had a little
little snuck up on you all real quick go
ahead what's the first topic all right
5 billion nearly triple its last
reported valuation of 36 billion from
april
2020. in some crazy world
i think that stripe is undervalued at 95
billion
wow and i think that stripes valuation
makes bitcoin look super cheap as well
so it's like both of them together
basically
you think bitcoins undervalued oh
completely
are you kidding me okay okay that's just
true bitcoin is more pervasive
and probably uh more important to the
world well definitely more important to
the world but like probably
right now from a pure user standpoint
and volume standpoint is probably more
uh
important in terms of uh metrics stripe
is an incredible uh business and product
i use both
and i think that stripe at 95 billion is
just
really really undervalued but my
favorite part about the whole thing
what is that they're from uh
ireland and they got the ireland
government
to lead the round is so cool
all right next amazon warming up for
like years now
but how do we feel that delivery
deliveroo is backed by amazon does that
matter
no i don't think it necessarily matches
i have no clue if this is
uh if this is a little laggy we're gonna
have to figure this out but if it's
laggy you don't have to deal with the
lag today okay i don't know what's going
we got a little camera action going on
whatever
uh i think that deliveroo which by the
way is a ridiculous name but awesome
name at the same time
uh is doesn't matter if it's backed by
amazon amazon wants financial exposure
of course
are they owned by amazon i don't think
so
durable capital partners fidelity
general catalyst index ventures excel
all the usual players getting in in the
game
if amazon's invested in it doesn't that
make deliveroo a potential acquisition
target for amazon
in what way amazon's an investor they
see how the business is doing they're
like
come come over here to the dark side if
it's going well
if it goes well sure but maybe they also
have other people on the cap table that
we don't know about that are like amazon
competitors who knows
doubt it ain't nobody at amazon
competitor other than shopify
so stimulus checks from president joe
biden's huge relief package
enacted last week or just making their
way out the door you might have
you might get them in your bank account
but while she is already looking ahead
to his administration's next priority
infrastructure
so um an analyst afs analyst said the
1.9 trillion stimulus has been adopted
without
much ado and divided administration has
now set its sights on a big
figure infrastructure bill so more money
more money printing more stuff
how big can we go this year we did 4
billion last year we already did 1.9
or i'm sorry excuse me uh that was a
mistake
not 4 billion 4 trillion last year we
already did 1.9 trillion this year
uh can we get to 10 let's just go for it
let's just do it
let's rip off a three trillion dollar
infrastructure bill it'll be
awesome we'll all celebrate asset prices
will go to the moon
we'll keep pushing people further and
further into financial uh despair and
we'll tell everyone inflation's not here
but even if food prices are going up gas
prices are going up consumer goods are
going up we'll say inflation's not here
i promise 1.6 uh cpi
how about this how about we actually
balance the budget how about you stop
trying to create money out of thin air
how about you take which i'm not even
gonna get into
your new tax uh proposal and you could
stuff that back down your guys throats
how about we say if you work in the
government
we're gonna take away your salary until
you balance the budget
that'd be financial incentive i bet you
we balance the budget real fast we do
not
have we do not have an income problem
for the government a revenue
uh problem for the government in this
country every year since 2011 they have
collected more
and more and more and more and more and
more of hard-working americans income
through the federal income tax
every year they've collected more but
every year at the same time
the yearly the annual deficit has
increased more and more more and more
and more
and so that means that literally the
problem is getting worse rather than
better even though they're collecting
more money it's a spending problem you
know why it's a spending problem because
of
dumb [ __ ] like this where literally they
want to create
two three trillion dollar infrastructure
packages
how about this stop dropping bombs in
other countries and use that to pay for
your infrastructure
that's a wild idea improve home rather
than go destroy abroad
that is just one idea that a normal sane
rational person would have but as we
know
politicians politicians are not
normal sane or rational people for the
most part and therefore they're going to
do dumb stuff like this
so you know what i opted out i hedged
myself i'm protected
i'll see whatever they do thank you
okay tesla ceo elon musk's tweets are
the subject of yet another
lawsuit a tesla investor is suing the
company board and musk for continuing to
send erratic tweets that violate a
settlement with the ussc
that requires oversight of the social
media activities
by someone else obviously there is no
someone else
elon is still being elon still tweeting
should what should we
what happens here i think that first of
all the lawsuit should be amended
to use his new title the techno king
which for those that don't know tesla
filed a uh
uh some paperwork with the sec and elon
has added to his chief executive officer
role
a new title the techno king of whatever
i forget what it's called
and the cfo's new title is master of
coin
literally in an sec filing they filed
and the cfo is now known as
master of coins this must not be like
bowed well with this investor who's
already pissed off
well guess what sorry that he's
delivered some of the best returns
on wall street if you don't like it get
out of the stock
if you like it buy the stock i bet
that's what he would say that's not
financial advice go ahead
oakland athletics announced full
season luxury suite packages that can be
bought for one bitcoin as of sunday that
was worth about sixty thousand dollars
oh we didn't even talk okay close to a
record high for the cryptocurrency
if paid in dollars a full season suite
package goes for about 65 000.
why do you think they're collecting
bitcoin the oakland days
bitcoiners ain't giving their bitcoin to
the oakland a's
we ain't giving our bitcoin to jamie
diamond and jp morgan
we ain't giving our bitcoin to goldman
sachs we ain't giving our bitcoin to the
oakland a's i don't care if billy beans
there or not that's a reference for you
sports fans out there
nobody's giving them their bitcoin i'm
willing to
bet zero bitcoin are sent
but this is very very very
smart because sorry somebody just
emailed me and just said i'm persistent
because they keep emailing me i'm
assuming uh and
the oakland a's are very smart because
this is a great marketing tactic it's
gonna drive a bunch of attention to
their suite people will be like oh how
much is a suite oh it's 65 000
what do i get for that is there free
food are the hamburgers and hot dogs
good
is the popcorn come with butter on top
when you should be asking are the
oakland a's gonna be good this year
go yankees all right which sport is this
should we talk about a rod and jayla
what sport is this baseball oh
a-rod and j-lo let's not talk about it
just just go just go to the questions i
don't want to hear any more about
the nonsense that you it's ask lunch
money time
ask ellen in the comments below all
right we're going to do this again
dimiter poupov asks no
he said hey pomplianos it's your friend
from bulgaria dimitrov
not poop lol i'm glad to see you where
martiniti
oh this i got i got mine on my question
is for both of you if you ever had to
leave the us where would you go and why
i would love to live in marbella for
example where is that what's that
where would you go probably italy
although now they're like locked down
again for a third wave of covet like
come on guys get your get your stuff
together
um i do i mean all my family's like in
bulgaria so that's that's an option
i'd go to mars come on
mars come on where would you go uh new
zealand
seems uh pretty chill new zealand seems
pretty chill
no australia seems pretty chill uh
singapore seems pretty chill uh maybe
not ash chill but a little chill
uh italy would be a great one um you
know
i could see myself in a little south
american uh country okay
you just named like every country
colombia maybe in a little columbiana
yeah you can see me there hey what up
that no it's you it's a
it's a it's a but i'm not okay
uh on top of that i could also see
myself maybe of one of my friends all my
technology friends they want to create
a seasteading uh civilization where you
basically pull together all the
the things and they float in the ocean
and international waters and create
their own rules yeah you don't know
about seasteading
but if somebody created a seasteading uh
civilization maybe i'd have to go check
that out
well you don't have to come but they
asked where i would want to live maybe
so that's all right uh or mars mars
mars might be cool okay moist update
moist counter
moist day 23 today god it's been a long
road
all right moist pump oh
sorry i don't care about age difference
with gabriella either
i like women that are older than i am
because i feel mature beyond my ears
my question for y'all is how did you
meet and start dating also when you
first started dating pomp how did you
simultaneously
show off your goofy and fun side while
also showing your manhood
and then you can be a serious provider
partner and whatnot moist
all right no moist gang hashtag unleash
the moisture he's become like a number
one voice fan hold on
we're not gonna get into it but moist i
have good news for you we met on the
internet kind of on twitter through
twitter
and then we got coffee so um she stalked
me on the internet i'll
i'll post the video here where we talk
about how we met and my chair falling
over it's a whole thing
uh she stalked me on the internet no
just go just go just go
wait are you going you gonna talk about
my manhood i don't want to talk about
that no it's you you go
i'm just me all the time literally
i've met some of the most important
people in the world on me
i meet some people who nobody ever will
ever even know their name
i'm me i hang out with weirdos all day
i'm me that's true moist be you
be you like i basically here's my
approach to life i'm gonna live my life
if you like me then you could be in my
life if you don't like me then see you
yeah facts but like at first i was very
jarred by him being him
and then i was like oh that's kind of
interesting yeah because i'm cool
anyway all right boys all you gotta know
is whatever i did
it worked she's wishing you the best of
luck
moist number one move uh dm the girl i
forget her name already
yeah gabriella cool dm her how do you
and just and just hit her with uh
you up like a letter u and then uh
question mark
and she'll laugh she'll think it's funny
gabrielle i know you could comment too i
know you think that that's funny
like you up how do you dm somebody on
youtube i don't know i don't even
understand how youtube works but that's
it for today and we will see you all
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends